I said earlier that the character Ariana
there's there's like varying degrees of
that person yeah and probably all of us
so what do you think most people would
see in themselves with Ariana maybe they
wouldn't go as far as some of the things
that she's doing in the fan but in terms
of like selling themselves doesn't have
to be sexually or with drugs but there
could be parts i mean that that we all
sort of sell ourselves yes well i think
everyone loses themselves in things and
it's hard it's hard for any human to
look in the mirror directly at
themselves and be honest with themselves
and with Ariana I think she looks in the
mirror and she's not honest at all like
I think she's completely like idea I
think she's lost herself but I can't
think of one person i know that hasn't
been completely lost at one point or
another um so i think people can relate
to her mostly because sometimes you just
get caught up and you're going to crowd
or a year in a situation or you're in a
new life everyone that pretty much
leaves their parents and goes wherever
they go that's that's usually such a
different world wind whether you're in
an apartment down the street or you're
just in college or you're on the other
side of the country or the other side of
the world you're all of a sudden an
adult and you make your own decisions
and sometimes you make decisions and
it's not your opinion you're using other
people's because you're too afraid of
your own and you just keep doing that
and doing that and you're not honest
with yourself you can't even look at
yourself in the mirror and I think
everyone has a point where they break
and they're like I don't know who I am
like I feel like 80 year old people can
still look in the mirror be like I don't
know who I am hey I don't know I don't
know what happened I don't know where I
went
I don't know what I missed but everyone
has regrets and as a young adult and a
whirlwind of new experiences I think
everyone can say that they've made
horrible mistakes that they wouldn't
want to admit to and that a lot of
people instead of apologizing to
themselves or to whoever and moving
forward and trying to do a clean slate a
lot of people make the mistake of
denying denying and going deeper and
deeper and getting darker and darker
because they don't want to admit the
truth because right when they do that's
the hardest part is realizing that you
are not perfect or that you messed up
and um I think a lot I think ariana is
Ariana is a troubled soul and I think
everyone is so I think in many ways
people can relate to her in any step of
life you just start lying to yourself
because it's easier
you